honey we only got a few moments so yeah
go out of here yeah my son is about to
turn 21 years old and he has except
excessive sweating he sweats all the
time doctor okay well he's an athlete in
college
he's a discus and shot the throwing but
even when he's sitting down here with us
he's just swept all the time inside that
he's pretty healthy and he had blood
tests I mean does he have blood sugar
problems ranging like that no no no
blood sugar problems
I think cholesterol was a little bit
high last time it came out but that's
about it
okay well I might be good because
anything below 250 is bad okay just you
know the doctors once you get down below
200 that's not good that's actually
incorrect okay so he's like 250 to 40 to
20 that's good okay so don't put him on
any stanton drugs all right now what is
he weigh 220 is about 84 okay Oh Tom
fell okay is he a student or working or
what he's a student is a student athlete
okay so he does play sports yeah okay so
one views a rebound
Mars for shrink has a hundred nutrients
in it 78 minerals the rest or vitamins
amino acids and things he has he has to
power he has six ours has 100 and then
we'd like him to have two of the health
of a nerd heart past four months two
healthy brain heart patch a month full
dose everything twice a day and then
throw in I'll see here I would also
throw in the gluco gel cause of the to
the large bowels of gluco gel 240 count
so you have 15 a day five at breakfast
lunch and dinner that's going to support
healthy a maintance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue just
between a burger a phone microphone
himself and lastly I'm going to have
2007 destress Capaldi like David - dress
and want him to take two bottles a month
of the distressing take three of those
capsules twice a day this has the
materials that he wants to have make us
adrenal glands happy so that they're
doing their job he may be being in a
fight or flight situation because the
subpoena lens are working properly makes
he's eating eight to ten eggs a day
Fordyce four to five the breakfast is
four to five at dinner time anything but
fried make sure the yolks are soft so we
can get the cholesterol so we can make
the adrenal hormones you can make
testosterone he'll be able to make all
the other cholesterol hormones and
you've been calling some tweaks in four
weeks in six weeks and if he does have
any respiratory stuff wheezing or asthma
if he's got skin problems eczema
dermatitis that stuff should go away
make sure again none of the bad stuff no
fried food no processed meats no oils
glutens